هذا مراسلنا بتواصل القصف بين قوات
الروسيه والاوكرانيه على محور بخموت
الاداره العسكريه في دونتسكا اعلنت ان
منطقه
كوستيان تنيفكا تعرضت للقصف خمس مرات
الليله الماضيه ما اسفر عن مقتل شخص
واصابه ثلاثه اخرين وفي بخمه تعلن المتحدث
باسم قياده الشرق في القوات الاوكرانيه
اكثر من خمسين اشتباك مع القوات الروسيه
يوم امس كما اتهم القوات الروسيه باطلاق
اكثر من 150 قذيفه باتجاه المواقع
الاوكرانيه هيئه الاركان العامه
الاوكرانيه قالاتنا مدن اوكرانيه عده
تعرضت للقصف واكدت الهيئه ان قوتها صدت 92
هجوما للقوات الروسيه باتجاه بخموت
ومارينكا وشختار وشرقي البلاد
وفي
اعلنت القوات الاوكرانيه ان وحدات تابعه
لها اشتبكت مع مسلحين من ميليشيات فاجنر
وقالت انها تمكنت من اسر احد المسلحين
وقتل اخر ونشرت القوات الاوكرانيه مقاطع
فيديو قالت انها من موقع الاشتباك الذي
اكدت انه اندلع بعد محاوله مسلحين من
فاجنر الاقتراب من مواقع تمركز للقوات
الاوكرانيه في المنطقه